jetzt reden natürlich immer mehr
menschen darüber brauchen wir jetzt
einen neustart oder zumindest den plan
dafür wie es nach der korona krise
weiter gehen soll und darüber möchte ich
jetzt sprechen mit spd
gesundheitsexperten karl lauterbach
guten abend herr lauterbach
diese sehr offensichtlich an sie denken
sie dass wir jetzt in deutschland den
neustart brauchen also einen neustart
ist wahrlich gefällt hier müssen wir aus
den maßnahmen die wir ergriffen haben
langsam ausgleichen wenn wir einen
neustart machen würde das bedeuten dass
wir quasi gefährden das was wir erreicht
haben das können wir uns auf keinen fall
leisten
wir müssen die maßnahmen dort locken wir
können und wir könnten uns mehr
lockerungen leisten wenn wir jetzt schon
fehler und platz hätte was der
sicherheit hier hilft beispielsweise
qualitativ hochwertige masken für die
bürger die sich im öffentlichen verkehr
aufhalten die also in berufen sich sehr
nahe kommen
wir bräuchten einer ecke um neue fälle
sehr schnell nachvollziehen zu können
andere sicherheitsvorkehrungen und ein
gutes konzept wie wir vorgehen dass ich
denke wir können aus den maßnahmen die
wir ergriffen haben nur langsam
ausgleichen
maximal und da müssen doch erstmal
abwarten was die zahlen bringen nach
ostern zum jetzigen zeitpunkt kann man
da noch gar keine entwarnung geben
weil die zahlen die wir also bisher
abend sind nach wie vor zu schlecht und
vom gas zu gehen
ich warne davor dass man hier zu sehr
drängelt auflockerung bringen und ladet
dann sag mal arzt gesellschaft und das
wirtschaft dann natürlich auch einen
schweren rückfall
das haben wir vor allem was die maßnahme
am anfang an gingen oft unseren
nachbarländern etwas hinterher
ja wir waren langsam auf jeden fall
unter anderem auch österreich und dort
kommt es jetzt schon zu lockerungen
warum kann die das aber wir nicht also
ob das was österreich jetzt versucht
erfolg gehabt das hat eigentlich das
werden wir noch sehen und auch so es ist
gut und wichtig zu sagen dass ich sehr
schnell
den lockdown beschossen das ist also
haben wir dann ja auch gemacht und ich
war ja auch andere ersten die das
gefordert haben in deutschland aber nach
genannt also muss man sagen haben im
vergleich zu anderen europäischen
ländern doch ganz gut ihr bisher
gehandelt wir sind ganz gut sagt ja
immer weggekommen bislang
umso wichtiger ist es dass wir es auch
durchhalten und nicht leichtsinnig
werden und wir müssen tatsächlich uns
auch jetzt die zeit nehmen wir müssen
die geduld haben abzuwarten was sind die
zusammen bei fakten nach ostern was
können wir da anbieten wir also niemand
wer so eine sperre hier willkürlich oder
länger als notwendig so durchziehen aber
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt bleibt einfach
nichts anderes übrig ist muss
durchstarten werden
wir haben wenig schutzmöglichkeiten von
der sozialen isolation abgesehen der rat
der stadt zur verfügung und können nicht
riskieren dass sie ältere und kranke
menschen und dann plötzlich da gewährt
werden wenn es dann nach den osterferien
zu einer neuen evaluierung der fakten
kommen sie natürlich schulen ein großes
thema was ist ihrer meinung das erste
was wieder geöffnet oder hochgefahren
werden sollte
also ich persönlich und das ist meine
eigene meinung darüber wird noch zu
diskutieren sein auch im rahmen der
beratung der bundesregierung mit dem
parlament aber ich persönlich halte es
für unmöglich dass man den schulbetrieb
ich sage mal nach den nach der osterzeit
regulär wieder anfährt also dass da
kinder sitzen in klassen mit bis zu 30
schülern auf engem raum die sich dann
auch noch in den pausen begegnen
das gefährdet natürlich sehr stark die
eltern und auch die lehrer jetzt kann
man sagen das sind oft junge leute das
stimmt nicht es gibt auch eltern
wir sind jetzt aber die haben noch
erkrankung und es gibt auch lehrer wird
das sind die kranken haben und wir
wollen ja auch nicht dass das virus sich
durch die gesamte bevölkerung dann
sozusagen wieder deutsch spricht daher
ein regulärer schulbetrieb wie wir ihn
vor wochen gekannt haben zudem werden
wir natürlich nicht sofort zurückkommen
können
da wird man langsam anfangen müssen
man sich zunächst wahrscheinlich also
auf also einen teil schulbetrieb also
konzentrieren müssen die konzepte dafür
werden gerade vorbereitet beim thema
schulen sind fällt natürlich auch dass
die sommerferien und auch bei allen
anderen
die temperaturen werden jetzt wärmer man
man freut sich eigentlich auf den sommer
aber denken sie das überhaupt die chance
gibt dass wir einen normalen sommer hier
in deutschland erleben werden
was würde auf keinen fall nochmal
normaler sommer werden zum normalen
sommer gehören zum beispiel offene cafés
dazu gehören restaurantbesuche abend
beim 1
dazu zählen aussagen was konzertbesuche
kinobesuche großereignisse
fußballspieler all das wird es
selbstverständlich nicht geben weil wir
sonst also innerhalb von kürzester zeit
unser kapital für spiegeln würden und
wir hätten sehr schnell wieder viele
fälle dann wäre dann auch so ein später
vielleicht auch sogar länger anhalten
das shut down notwendig mit
entsprechenden also demoralisierenden
konsequenzen für die bevölkerung und
schockierenden wirkungen für die
wirtschaft das kann die macht es gibt
daher der sommer wird nicht viel
ähnlichkeit haben mit dem sommer den wir
im letzten jahr erleben durften
vielen dank für ihre einschätzung dazu
wie es jetzt in den kommenden wochen und
monaten hier in deutschland weitergeben
wird